what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so it's been a couple weeks since
we made one of these Theory videos
largely it's because last week was
Memorial Day weekend and I figured
people were just kind of hanging out and
about and going out with friends and
family and I was back in Lexington and
so on and so forth
ah but I want to talk about the enigma
force specifically in relation to like
Ant Man and wasp and Avengers 4 because
ant-man wasp could actually bring that
in they could bring the enigma force and
Captain universe into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with Avengers 4 now
would be an enigma force in Captain
universe turned the tide right like if
Captain universe showed up in Avengers 4
what captain universe be able to like
single-handedly defeat you know they
announced or something like that
absolutely not like like probably not I
mean captain universe has always been a
cool concept but captain universes
powers are relative like they're not an
absolute thing and so because that you
kind of have to take it with a grain of
salt right you have to sort of just roll
with it and and see what happens and
just kind of hopefully things to her now
cool uh when it comes to the enigma
Force itself though that goes all the
way back to 1977 with no I'm sorry not
to 78 I think it was with micronauts
number 8 so a little bit of history here
back in the the 1970s at Marvel Comics
it was pretty much just write whatever
you want to write I mean like Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby had created a bunch of
superheroes and brought back some
superheroes with their their
inauguration of Marvel Comics such as it
was in the 1960s and that in turn led to
you like this huge proliferation of
characters like superheroes from DC and
Marvel and everybody was creating all
different kinds of stuff well because of
the success of what Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby had done in the 1970s when you had
Jim shooter as editor-in-chief there
were a bunch of things that went on uh
one was securing comic books based on
toy lines right so you had like you had
Larry Utley with larry Hama
um but you had like like one of somebody
one of the editors in chief or one of
the editors wherever it was basically
brought on board like GI Joe and then
you had like the Secret Wars which was
the original Secret Wars was designed to
be a story that could showcase the most
popular characters in Marvel Comics and
that was designed to secure a toy deal
from Mattel so there were a lot of
things that were going on behind the
scenes but what ended up happening is if
les Daniels the come of a historian is
to be believed what ended up happening
is one of the writers of the time bill
Mantlo which I believe this predates his
run on the
Hulk but I could be wrong but bill
Mantlo had actually like his son was
opening up a present or something like
that it was like micronauts these little
toys they made back in the day and bill
Mantlo wanted to write comics based on
those toys for son and so I Jim shooter
was like whatever man go with it just do
whatever you want to do so bill Mantlo
gave us Micronauts and micronauts was
largely stand-alone but it was basically
by itself I mean it took place inside
the Marvel Universe but it didn't really
cross over what the rest of the model
universe I mean it did to a degree but
not in the capacity of like Fantastic
Four x-men Avengers different things
like that like you really wouldn't see
the micronauts team-up now that changed
in like 1987 with Fantastic Four 282
which was a tie-in for the second Secret
Wars event ah there was basically
capitalizing on the first one that's
really the most popular of the of the
iterations if you don't take into
account the the modern-day version which
is kind of a continuation kind of not
but because of that what is it I'm
happening here is a Fantastic Four
actually traveled to the Microverse and
that's when you basically learn of a lot
of really a lot of what goes on behind
the scenes in terms of accessing the
Microverse by mainline superheroes and
so what you have is you have the main
Marvel Universe right like the huge
universe in its entirety F Thanos and
going into the galaxy and the Kree and
the scrolls and the and all these
different things the Shiar Empire and
the x-men Avengers Fantastic Four you
have all those things inside of the
Marvel Universe on an exceedingly small
microscopic level is a whole other
universe called the Microverse ah now
you can the only way that I know of and
I'm pretty sure the Fantastic Four
established this outside of mystical
means like if you were Doctor Strange
but the only way to really to really
access this is to shrink down using Pym
particles and then enter into the
Microverse now you'd have to shrink down
at an astronomically small level because
you're talking about a microscopic
universe and then the citizens inside
that universe are even smaller than that
so I mean you'd have to shrink down to
an exceedingly miniscule level but it
did introduce the idea that like the
main the the the Microverse could cross
over into the main Marvel Universe and
the micro the micronauts and the
Microverse were pretty popular I mean
the series ran for 59 issues which is
even four back then is a pretty lengthy
stent for a series if it wasn't very
popular I mean Marvel doesn't really
like back then they don't really do what
they do now like nowadays on Marvel
Comics if a series doesn't sell they
just cancel it
don't really hand it over to a new
writer they just get rid of it and so
because they it's kind of a lazy way to
handle stories but back then they would
just hand the story over to somebody
else and just say here you write it and
that's how you got things like bill
Mantlo and Peter Davis Incredible Hulk
run that's how you got things like
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four is
they would just give it to a different
writer and the writer would just work
wonders with it but with regards to the
idea of the enigma force really the
captain universe concept premiered and
micronauts number eight and so all we
really knew is that the enigma force can
possess a person and that's it that's
all we really knew but going forward
after Fantastic Four 282 and running up
into the modern day the the expansion of
the Enigma force and the expansion of
the role of Captain universe while it
hasn't been the biggest thing ever it
certainly shed a lot more light on what
goes on and so the way this works is the
Microverse is quote-unquote powered by
the enigma force but Marvel's never
explained it hence the name Marvel
doesn't really say the purpose the
enigma for serves outside of providing
an energy source basically for the
Microverse they don't really say how it
relates to like eternity for example in
the main Marvel Universe they don't
really say any of that stuff they just
say like the enigma forces there and the
idea is that in times of great need
which is to say an event that endangers
the entirety of the universe because the
Microverse is part of the main Marvel
Universe if the main Marvel Universe
were to be destroyed the Microverse
would be destroyed along with it and so
in response to that because the Enigma
force exists to basically protect itself
to ensure its own survival what it'll do
is it'll leave the Microverse or at
least allow a facsimile of itself to
leave the Microverse and then a portion
of that power will be bestowed onto an
individual and they'll become captain
universe now the role of Captain
universe is waxing waned over the years
and the way that Marvel makes this work
is they say that for the most part
there's never really an instance where
like a baseline human with no powers
will become Captain universe it's
happened on a couple of occasions
actually but it's not something you see
happen all the time instead it's a way
to actually just kind of tell a fun
story with a superhero for example there
was one point where spider-man got the
Enigma force and punched the Incredible
Hulk into the atmosphere so like that
was cool that was actually a pretty cool
event Spiderman was totally amazed by
like how much power he had but by and
large the Enigma force possesses your
standard gamut of superheroes
super-strength I'm sorry superpowers
rather a super strength speed durability
flight you know different things
like that channeling cosmic energies but
it's not always the same what the enigma
force will usually do is when a person
it bonds with the ending before it will
basically enhance their abilities and
that's really about it by and large when
a person is given the name of force it's
like Univision basically um allowing
them to essentially see things in a
subatomic scale and then like some
measure of cosmic awareness depending on
how Marvel wants to tell the story but
again it really waxes and wanes for
example most recently in Marvel Comics
during the events of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers we've got a
new captain universe and she was just
kind of like you guys are screwed like
there's nothing you guys can do to stop
the collapse of the multiverse because
you know you're dealing with powers way
beyond your ability to comprehend which
of course was revealed to be the ivory
Kings who wiped out all of the cosmic
entities destroy the Living Tribunal and
then dr. doom destroyed them using the
molecule man Owen Reese or at least like
15 versions of molecule man Owen Reese
stole their power create a battle world
and became gods so like it gets kind of
crazy when you get into that whole like
God king doom and all that kind of crazy
stuff but the cool thing about rolling
over Captain universe into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is again you can
basically have a set of events whereby
ant-man and wasp for whatever reason end
up shrinking down into the Microverse
and because Thanos wiped out half the
life in the universe and infinity war
you can push that into the Microverse
and say half of their population is gone
as well and so where they're trying to
figure it out in response to the crisis
the Enigma force basically sends a
facsimile of itself to the the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe which picks a
new host and that person becomes Captain
universe I wouldn't really see it being
something that would turn the tide right
like I don't really see it being like a
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel esque sort
of situation where like she shows up on
the scene and the day is saved which is
apparently what they're gonna be going
for in the film from what I see or I
could just see it as like introducing a
new concept and that's the way it was a
Marvel like you didn't see Captain
universe all that often you might see a
host for Captain universe and they would
be a host for like a year in Marvel
Comics but I think overall there's
probably been like seven maybe Kathleen
universes I'll remember the number off
the top of my head but it's been like
less than 20 like it's not been that
many people it's not something you see
all the time so again it'd be kind of
cool you know I think it'd be
interesting just to sort of have a new
character thrown in there not really for
the sake of having them but for the you
know at the very least expanding on the
existing roster but let me know what you
guys think
the comments section ah those of you
guys who are familiar with captain
universe let me know if you're not
familiar we could probably do a
discussion but in reality what you've
seen here is really all there is to know
at this point you're just breaking it
down into like who was captain universe
when they were captain universe and why
they play that role and even in the case
of spider-man just who possess the
enigma force because spider-man didn't
actually become captain universe as far
as I'm aware it was just spider-man with
the enigma Force which was kind of cool
but let me know what you guys think down
in the in the comments section and yeah
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]